faut-il avoir peur d'une guerre civile
et surtout faut-il tirer à balles
réelles
c'est vrai que ça c'est un débat qu'on
entend depuis sedan plus et qui nous
fait un petit peu flipper 1
on va pas se mentir alors faut-il avoir
peur d'une guerre civile moi je me
tourner d'abord vers michel michel vous
êtes l'auteur de cette lettre adressée
au président dont qui a été publiée dans
valeurs actuelles enfin vous non pas
vous mais là elle avait aussi une lettre
publiée par l'hebdomadaire actuel il
freine pas toutes les lettres non plus
est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut y
avoir une guerre civile
mais je pense que malheureusement on y
est déjà quand tous les soirs toutes les
nuits nos collègues sont attaquées avec
la volonté de les tuer ils prennent des
cocktails molotov qu'ils sont tirés avec
des tirs tendus de d'artifice ya une
volonté aujourd'hui tu es les collègues
on a deux connecte sur le caron 2e en 12
jours mais une collègue qui a été égorgé
à l'accueil du commissariat
un autre qui a été tué par un arc aux
terroristes donc aujourd'hui oui on en
guerre si l'idée qu'il existe à police
bashing et que les français ne croient
plus en la justice oui c'est évident on
l'a vu avec la sphère sarah halimi et
francine croit plus à la justice et
police bashing permanent aujourd'hui
quand il ya la moindre affaire il ya
monsieur chouf yake sur le plateau alors
ils traitent les collègues de vermine
mais aujourd'hui la justice nana na na
nana na na na na la retraite les
collectes les cadres ambitieux c'est 4 à
500 déchets tuer je traite les katas
socialement la virilité par les 100%
aujourd'hui depuis bon combat il a
démarré il ya 99% de de gens bien dans
la police terrain pour son nom mais pour
l'instant rien n'a pas su y croire et ça
n'a pas été jugée bien maigre laisser la
justice faire et après vous pourrez vous
parlez 160 500 tonnes ils aboutissent en
jeu j'étais vous je suis à 100 km/heure
savez sur les 4 yards à ça je vous le
dis ah bon ils paieraient cesc est ce
que est ce que la s e mail adressé par
les cieux si c'est pour mieux attaquer
ce que vous connaissez pas vous en
parler mais c'est parce que vous savez
pas ce que vous parlez chez monsieur que
ce que vous dites c'est exact je suis
désolé mais michel comprenez bien c'est
aussi les mots d'un papa qui a perdu son
fils mais je suis jean trajean suis
compatissant mais aujourd'hui il
faudrait pas nombreux malheureusement
que les médias exploitent la souffrance
d'un père pour jeter le propre d'une
audition qui était passager le la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est qu'on vit une
situation qui n'est plus acceptable
aujourd'hui notre organisation syndicale
demain
2 une réforme de la légitime défense les
policiers ne peuvent pas se défendre
aujourd'hui vous donnez à vos besoins et
que vous pouvez ouvrir vous demander à
pouvoir ouvrir le feu sur les fuyards
non on n'a pas on demande aujourd'hui
clairement que dans le thème adopté une
urgence en hurlantes une réforme de la
légitime défense pour les peaux lui est
abaissé à dar absolument aujourd'hui
quand nos collègues sont attaquées avec
par exemple des cocktails molotov
il faut effectivement c'est armelle et
létales il faut qu'on puisse avoir un
texte aujourd'hui qui nous permette de
riposter
pareil sur les contrôles routiers n'est
absolument pas normal aujourd'hui des
collègues se façon ci dessus qu'on
utilise des armes pour tuer mes
collègues et que mes collègues ne puisse
pas riposter aujourd'hui donc oui on a
absolument besoin qu'une sur ce point là
sur ce point là est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec michel ou pas du tout sur
ce point là sur le point la légitime
défense est sur le point de pouvoir
rétorqué oui vous êtes d'accord nicolas
sûr légitime défense berry violon je
suis je suis d'accord mais de l'autre
côté il ya d'autres choses à faire avant
quand même ya des problèmes de formation
aujourd'hui chez verizon
donc on peut pas non plus grand des
petits jeunes car oui mais il ya les
problèmes de formation il ya les autres
les objectifs
d'accord vous me répondez sur légitime
défense mais attend de noix sur des
prestations
quand vous parlez d'un pourcent
attention qui est pas des gens qui
s'engagent ils tirent sur le premier
venu vous bernard ou bernard vous
comprenez ce que d'une chaîne là dessus
sourit je comprends tout à fait je
comprends surtout la détresse des
policiers qui est très grave il faut
vraiment s'en occuper parce que là ça va
pas du tout il a belle morini-bosc aussi
oui mais aussi sur tout mais ce qui
s'est passé cette semaine on ne peut pas
ne pas dire mais oui il faut quand même
ils ne répondent de la loi oui alors si
vie pareille moi aussi je suis
totalement d'accord je soutiens et c'est
mon dieu que je me répète fait que cette
période compliquée et fils numérique
alors et pour montrer aussi quand vous
entendez ça monsieur sous verre mais
alors un mot un groupe de 14 15 ans il
vole une mobylette
oui non il fait un délit de fuite on lui
tire dessus on a on a mal réagi
on n'avait jamais dit ça mais basée sur
des gens qui vous avez un individu qu'à
voler un porsche cayenne et utilise ce
porche cayenne pour volontairement
shooter un collègue il a effectivement
faut qu'on puisse utiliser là une arme
l' arme à feu évidemment va pas tirer
sur un jeune qui a volé un scooter face
est totalement dérisoire il faut en
aucun cas les mines aura plus de
synchronisation et non l'inconscience
ça c'est votre position aujourd'hui là
où il ya plein mellier c'est cesser dans
le cadre de mes collègues qui se font
assassiner on a deux deux collègues au
carreau depuis douze jours alors vous ça
vous dérange pas mais nous je suis
désolé je suis à zéro je me souviens je
suis tout petit doigt dessus sur avec la
famille d'éric je suis tout cas je sais
ça merci parce que on a les mêmes
problèmes aujourd'hui ça peut vous
emmener des familles en deuil je vous
aurais sans doute avant perdu un mari un
père et un fils mais qu'on avait nos
moyens d'action la police c'est
l'abstraction transamo tu meurs je vous
dis qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir
une réforme de la légitime défense qui
permettent de protéger des pères de
famille avant la visite défense alves
est de faire régner la justice
quant à gary qui sort du thème visage à
la démission de dupond moretti de pas
mal d'émoi échéant aujourd'hui gelée 17
justice ne correspond plus aux attentes
du peuple
quand j'essaie brandon mort était
aventuré fait c'était pareil c'est plus
sombre et versez-la jura l'ipad dupont
bri aimé ce que c'est lui qui est en
panne à tout le monde c'est normal
ford et on l'a vu encore une fois avec
sarah dit me jean cys encore sur celle
qui est ample et matic où la justice n'a
pas été rendue à exhaler aujourd'hui il
ya une fracture entre la justice et la
population et m'y intéresser par là bas
messieurs justice la facture aller sur
la justice aurait pas sur la politique